the jurgen experience now do you cook
yeah oh yeah he made what you went top
chef chopped celebrity tournament
so you're a chef chef no he's just like
a home chef but i'm good at
taking what's there and making something
out of it like random stuff what are you
into like what do you like to cook
um i like italian food i like you know i
mean
out here when you know you go to the
farmer's market there's all great stuff
that's
in season all the time and i don't know
soup i'm really good at really
yeah whatever's i mean yeah and i did it
because my wife doesn't cook she's
you know she's a designer she's good at
building things so
i if i wanted to eat good i had to learn
how to cook because she's
so you learned out of necessity and then
really got into it yeah
not well i mean i got into it because i
you know i liked
feeding like you know i liked eating
good so
but i did this i got offered to be on
this show i never
i didn't even know the show my kids were
like no you'd go and do this
you'll win if you do this show because
you you're good at like cooking with
random ingredients
and it was um 16 people
like one day it was actors four actors
four comedians four athletes and four
like musicians
then the winner from each day does the
last day and how do they judge based on
taste presentation
yeah three three professionals judge
uh creativity and what did you cook
well i did yeah i used ice cream i made
a dessert you have to make
this three rounds every day right so is
it appetized around a
main course and then a dessert but for
the desserts i made ice cream and i put
like booze in the ice cream
and that got over really good like
bourbon bourbon ice cream
vanilla bourbon nice tequila ice cream
or something like that but they give you
weird
[ __ ] like um in one you open this box
and these ingredients you have to use
then you have a pantry with all the
other like normal staples of all kinds
of other vegetables and
like what would be in the box um
fake blood like candy blood or like
unpop an
unpopped uh dry corn on the cob
unpopped you know like like it's like
popcorn but not
off the um squid
it was like um that's kind of more of a
normal thing
so you have to have pretty well-rounded
skills
yeah and then it's timed but then the
the thing i didn't think about that's
the hardest thing
is that there's cameras in your face the
whole time which is really hard and then
if they follow you around
awkward move around the kitchen yeah
you're trying to cook really fast and do
something someone's right here with the
camera
right that kind of thing what what do
you what the [ __ ] do you do with
unpopped corn
well i knew what to do with it which was
good you put it in a paper bag
and then put it in the microwave and
then you got popcorn and you could do
stuff with it but i had
i had bought it at the farmers market
like the week before just by chance
oh wow so i knew what to do with it yeah
i would have been [ __ ]
um and you cook for your family you win
50 000 for charity that's that was the
the thing but i wound up winning the the
last two people were me and brandy
chastain you know she was on the u.s
women's soccer team not the recent one
but back then she took off her
shirt and was wearing the sports bra
that was the famous photo or something
it was
her and i were the two finalists did she
do that after the show
that's her movie lost she does that with
everything maybe if she won she may come
in second
no you don't do that when you come
inside yeah you got to do that for first
place
i did it you should have pulled your
balls out
so so when you're doing this thing
so when you're doing this you get all
these ingredients like what what it what
is your thought process like
what kind of you get the squid and the
popcorn so you you
how much time are you getting by the way
um for i think for the appetizers you
have 15 minutes
15 minutes so you open up the box you've
got 15 minutes to make something you're
going to make so you're looking at the
squid you're looking at the popcorn
you're like [ __ ]
yeah and you have to make and then
there's uh there's all different
machines
too there's like a food processor
there's an ice cream machine there's
like a sous-vide machine which is
you put stuff in a paint in the plastic
seal it and then put it into like really
hot water and cook it that kind of [ __ ]
if you want to get adventurous yeah wow
you had to try one
try one of these shows no not for you no
i'm not interested
what do you make